he told me listen i i have the online
store and i have
um
a facebook community and i keep trying
to get the facebook fans out of facebook
to my store and maybe we could just do
the opposite and bring the products off
the store into facebook and this was
actually the the initial idea behind the
story
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's meet
an unconventional startup meet yariv
duro co-founder and ceo of storia
he has been the ceo of storya.com for
the past 10 years a profitable startup
that automated performance-based
advertising on behalf of e-commerce smbs
and is serving four hundred thousand
merchants from 186 countries
shifted his career 15 years ago from a
law internship for judge estera youth to
an online advertiser for 888.com and for
minoboost.com
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
for joining me from the store ya offices
how are you
thank you michael i'm very good and i
appreciate the opportunity to be here
software is eating the world everything
is moving online everything is digital
marketing and advertising turned from
television radio and billboards to the
online sphere and that is exactly where
you came in 10 years ago as co-founder
and ceo of storia and today you've been
working with more than 400 000 sellers
to help them
advertise better
really becoming an expert and online ads
whether it be google facebook whatever
it may be and so i'm really looking
forward to understanding you know your
perspective into the market hear the
story of storia and that's enough for me
welcome
thank you very much
tell me a little bit about yourself and
and the founding a story of storia
sure so i'm 44 married to a clinical
psychologist
interesting
yeah
i was the captain in the uh
idf but in the artillery forces not the
eighth two hundred
um i initially studied to be a lawyer
and i was an intern for the israeli
president of the supreme court
and but my actual school was rateday.com
where i learned how to do performance
advertising and made a lot of money for
that company
and that was about 15 years ago and
everything's this is why this is my
professional i'm an online advertising
uh person and
i i joined another
profitable startup after 888
it was founded by
x888 employees
uh in that
startup i founded the marketing
department
and in the past
nine years i'm the co-founder and ceo of
storia beautiful okay so yeah
paint me first of all the landscape 10
years ago your founding storia what is
um online advertising and and why why
create a company in that space
um so the the idea and the vision were
actually of my partner and brother a
real life um who is that who has the
soul of an independent
um
and
he was actually an online retailer
and and he came with the idea because he
had an online store and he told me
listen i have the online store and i
have
a facebook community and i keep trying
to get the facebook fans out of facebook
to my store
and maybe we could just do the opposite
and bring the products off the store
into facebook and this was actually the
the initial idea behind storia
because we figured out that if he needs
that and there is no solution for it
uh we can actually automate it on behalf
of all the smbs out there
and this is what we do like we we
um
we were joined by our cto pasha zaft and
he actually
taught the the computer to
extract the feed of products from any
um e-commerce store
and and generate a new store inside the
the facebook arena
and that was the the first product that
we developed 10 years ago
and 15 products later
we are focused on on more stuff uh i'll
i'll be happy to to uh
uh elaborate on
that
we're gonna get there very soon but
first i want to um you know uncover a
little bit about the process that you've
that you underwent to you know find
product market fit and find the right
way to work with these smbs because you
have two challenges here right you're
both developing a product that will help
the smbs but then you have to do that at
scale almost in in a b2c like manner
where
obviously then you've reached hundreds
of thousands and so you know what what
is sort of the process that you led
yourself and your co-founder to find
this product market fit
um so
you're right everything that we ever
developed was always a complete sas of
software as a service always
totally automatic this is what enabled
us to
um
serve over 400
000 merchants from
186 countries around the world uh with
with a team of only 12 people
and we always think to have the the
minimal uh walk on on the
merchant's end
like
one to three clicks the most uh because
we don't expect the merchant to be doing
the work we want our system to be doing
the work and everything needs to be
automated
if it has one click for for us it's not
it's not
set up uh it needs to be zero clicks on
our end and
the maximum of three clicks on the
merchant's end
um
what was the most challenging part to to
reach this phase two because you know
with the end zero clicks and you earned
three clicks on there and obviously had
to go through many iterations what was
the
what was what are the process like for
you
um
i i guess the the
reaching out to those merchants i mean
technically uh uh our cto pasha could
build a
ship to the moon uh
it can do anything but we always need to
find a way to
reach out to the merchants and explain
to them in
what they are going to
achieve by using our tools
and
why is that important for them
i i think this was and still is the the
um
the most challenging we try to do it in
in many different uh
aspects on one end uh from day one pasha
generated
email addresses for us to reach out
through email marketing
from another end always seek to do
business development
with companies that group
together um online merchants and can
help us in in reaching out to all all of
those uh merchants in
at once
um either by displaying us in uh and
their marketing efforts or their app
store or
whatever
right now so if fast forward 10 years
today you've mentioned you've had quite
a few iterations on the product what is
if the vision before was to you know to
allow them to do
to you know automatically extract those
different items and create those stores
and a lot of them to do better marketing
what is where is storya today what is
sort of the core mission of this company
so our flagship product is the traffic
booster which fully automates google
facebook instagram and big
advertising on behalf of those uh small
to medium businesses
and
by fully automating i mean that once the
merchants submit is the domain
geo-targeting preferences and initial
paid plan
our system would set up the accounts for
him in google and facebook and optimize
those accounts um in real time and
report back with the money that uh went
out in each channel
and
the the traffic booster covers all of
google and facebook advertising channels
and
the initial extraction of
the the feed of products that we built
uh 10 years ago is still serving us in
this in this product because
we we extract the product and then we
modify them uh to fit each and every
advertising method of google and
facebook
fantastic now if you look at the the
last 10 years and obviously you're
living the online advertising space day
in and day out what what has changed you
know where what what's different today
than it was 10 years ago from your
perspective
wow everything
it's it's what i love about this world
is that it is so uh
dynamic and
10 years ago like you had
in google maybe only the the search and
things then you have dynamic search and
you have shopping and smart shopping and
now the pmax
entered the world
it's it's a totally different ballgame
than it was 10 years ago
10 years ago facebook was not that
great of
advertising platform for
e-commerce smbs and nowadays it's it's a
fantastic one um because they really
um
did a great uh progress during those
years
uh in in targeting the the the the
rights
potential customers for each uh merchant
if you know how to use their their
system correctly
um
so
really
a totally different ballgame in in my
eyes
so have are you identifying that the
biggest pain point in today's online
advertising space is the ability to
quickly and efficiently deploy
these targeted advertisements through
the abundant
you know
platforms is that is that the main pain
point that small businesses have that
you are solving with storia
um yeah the the main point is always how
to acquire a new potential customers
um
you know
previously we developed tools that
enabled the merchants to
actually
double and even triple their conversion
rate of the store and it wasn't enough
because the smb
uh
maintain would always be how to get the
the
the next
thousand or ten thousand and new
potential customers to store
and yes
this is what we
um we came up with we we
might my partner
my cto pasha
tried to to
convince me for years
that uh online advertising can be
automated and i kept telling him listen
every time i optimize an account it's
it's something different and i need to
to use my brain in order to to to do it
and he told me no no you will find the
pattern and i will teach the the system
to to uh run it automatically and in
real time and as always he was right
it can be automated and it should be
automated because this way you you get
better results and also
you are able to walk with a larger um
number of merchants and with a larger
number of of products because if if you
have stores with thousands or tens of
thousands of products and you try to
optimize them manually you will not go
very far you will always be advertising
the same
um
products and not the entire scope of
products
right and so
if you're looking at your own journey as
an entrepreneur and you know trying to
reflect back on these 10 years
what were some of the most exciting
moments for you on a on a personal level
because really you've i have the
privilege of speaking to somebody who's
built a real business you know over 10
years it's not a traditional you know
b2b sas company that aims to exit after
two or three years here you've built a
real business that is generating real
revenue generating real value for
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses what was the most exciting or
a few of the most exciting pieces or
stories from your own journey
um
so what makes a stick is is
to really enable the smbs to be using
tools that normally only enterprise
would be able to use
and to get a
thank you letter from a seller saying
listen you helped me fulfill my dream
and i have now the
um tuition to to learn in an iv
league school
because i was able to to make money due
to your
platform
that's an excitement
and to be able to
split
dividends back to
our investors and to be to become a
profitable company over the years
that's exciting
and
and and
to be able to go through
um
large uh
sales cycles of enterprises like two
years ago uh google
introduced us to to paypal paypal came
to google and asked to have
integration with google and google told
them listen we already have a partner
that did all of that
just walk directly through
a story
and and people say okay we will check
you out and it took two years of long
poc in which wow paypal
um
drove the merchants from their end and
even
um
provided the advertising budget uh in
one condition that the merchant would
share
the
uh performance they had before
using storia and while during
while using story and so to
overcome this
two years of poc and to ceo up in
paypal's recently
launched a app store as the sole
solution for advertising for all of the
paypal merchants
that that's something that
uh
is very very
exciting it's a roller coaster of two
years and and it has it this one had a
happy ending
incredible if you
had to reflect back on the single most
challenging moment you've had
whether it be i you know personally with
a company professionally with a company
with the product
what what what are what is you know a
moment that was really rough as an
entrepreneur that you overcame
um
i i don't want to rank
there were
quite a few over a period of 10 years
and
i guess
fundraising was
um
a tough experience
to
um
the climate was not as it uh today it
was i think and much harder to uh um
raise funds for a startup 10 years ago
and
it took much longer
i mean after shaking hands
it took us
five five months and then it took us
nine months and and to wait for nine
months and
most startups would probably won't have
the the um
the air to wait for it
and but being a profitable startup it
actually helped us in in those scenarios
and
so that's an excitement
roller coaster of of working with paypal
or google or facebook which are you know
they are enterprises they work
differently than startup
it's always a challenging um
to to
find the ways to to work together to
collaborate
and we have been doing it for a few
years with those companies
so i don't want to rank but
many challenges during 10 years
i can only imagine and and i play a game
with me you know thinking a little bit
ahead you know on the online world is
obviously changing and everything is
becoming digital and you have an influx
of of small businesses all around the
world that are forced to move digital
and obviously that com comes with it
also their advertising campaigns and
needs
how do you see the online advertising
world changing even in just in the next
two or three years what should we be
expecting and what should we be focusing
on right now
um actually we already played that game
in march 2020
when the pandemic hit the world and
um
for
existing sellers of ours that were
already selling online in
april and may 2020 where
like uh
november it was like black friday a day
and
every day for for two months
for brick and mortar stores uh that only
switched to
online during the pandemic
um
i i believe we were the the lifeboat
because they really need to to
to found the traffic and that we were
able to drive to their uh
new stores
and and this was their oxygens in in
those times
and
as i see it
people that now
became familiar with
making their purchases online
um
are
likely to to get used to it and and to
like it and so the e-commerce world is
is only going to benefit and and
and and get
stronger out of of the the other side of
the pandemic
i love it
i really want to want to thank you and
this was such a an enjoyable
conversation getting to know you and
getting to know storia and the online
advertising world and hearing your
perspective from 10 years ago to today
some of the points along the journey and
how you see it and and obviously you
know the amazing impact that you've had
on hundreds of thousands of businesses
and you know helping them get to the
right people and doing it
with with very very little effort so
thank you very much best of luck with
the future of story as you continue
pushing hard as the world continuously
changing and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you mikhail it was a
pleasure
[Music]